so how long has this been going on this
thing it's not four months four months
five months she's right attaboy better
get used to saying that oh boy
that is from the box-office hits get out
critics predict it will be a Best
Picture contender at the Academy Awards
it was written and directed by comedian
turned horror movie director horror
movie director Jordan Peele the thriller
follows a black man who meets his white
girlfriends family for the first time
this is a social commentary on race
relations in America peel as you know
got his big break back in 2003 when he
joined the sketch comedy series MADtv he
created and starred in the emmy-winning
series key & peele with fellow MADtv
alum keegan-michael key in 2012 their
popular sketch about President Obama's
anger translator showed fields knack for
impersonating the former president I
just want to say to my critics I hear
your voices and I'm aware of your
concerns
you know that goes for everybody
including members of the Tea Party even
get me started on mismo right here I
want to assure you that we will be
looking for new compromises with the GOP
and the months ahead you know what he's
gonna say no before you can say yes it
is still funny
Jordan feel welcome back to the table
the other funny thing you guys used to
do is mess up people's names you were
like see Harley Rose yes hi Yardley see
Harley I wrote that was very unfunny
let's talk about get out all at the
tables seen the movie yeah
and I've seen it three times I'd see it
twice in one week just to do the
translation but what is the story Jordan
you were trying to tell cuz when I heard
Jordan Peele horror movie I went what
you know I was trying to bring a piece
of the conversation I had never seen put
on film before I felt like there was
this void in the way we talk about race
especially at the time when I wrote it
which was actually very similar time to
when we wrote the the Obama Luther
translator sketch we felt like racism
was not being called
doubt sufficiently enough for you said
you're trying to tell your own truth
what is that well really much my truth
as a black man you know that my
perspective that I haven't seen in film
before I haven't I haven't seen that
represented like so like it well in the
party scene and get out
for example there's it's a scene where
you know it's a group he's the only
black guy it's a bunch of older white
people who are trying to connect with
him with on his blackness first saying
things like you know I know Tiger and
that that's the situation that I've been
in yeah I think every minority has been
I think I think I imagine you you know
if you're a woman in a room full of men
you're viewed as a woman before you're
viewed as a human being and it's those
little it's you know on the surface it's
a harmless thing but what I wanted to
point out with this film is that it's
connected to the the real the deep
horror of racism I was doing scary
movies similar to doing comedy great
question I mean they're both from either
both about truth if you if you if you're
not accessing something that feels true
you're not doing it right and it there
also the technique of them you have to
be very tuned in to the audience and
their their emotion and that's why with
both both both forms the the technique
is tension building and release what's
interesting about you and from previous
conversation with you you wanted to be a
filmic what before you wanted to be a
comedian
yeah yeah comedy was an access to get
going I get well I got I got a
sidetracked with an amazing a fortunate
comedy career which was which was you
know a joy you know this yes I spent 10
years laughing and you know but I had
something else to say and I had
something I think a more important
statement that I had to put in a
long-form but he's interesting the the
stories about the the black guy who goes
to meet his white girlfriend's family
and the horror that unfolds before with
that did the fact that you were married
to a white woman did that play into the
story you were trying to tell it's a
it's one of these like blink three times
if you're in trouble before I met my
wife yes so I can't claim I'm very
fortunate very lucky you know I married
a comedian so she you know she gets it
she's very cool pick up on that because
you were able to beautifully weave
comedy into this movie as well I have
newfound appreciation for TSA agents one
is actually a sort of hero in this movie
how important was it to include comedy
obviously not taking away from the drama
and in the thriller that the movie
really is it's pretty important you know
I'm putting my audience through a lot
with this movie a lot of tension a lot
of uncomfortable situations it is and
and there there are moments it's hard to
watch there's moments you want to scream
get out yes and so we're you know little
rel Howery who plays rod you know his
character was kind of the release valve
for the audience and it was important
for me that he comes in and he he speaks
the truth too so there's not there's no
line that's intended for there's no
jokes in the movie it's all it's all
meant to feel true it's all meant to
kind of feel like the most true thriller
horror thriller we've seen so far and
you address how people deal with racism
in the country one of the easiest lines
to throw out is I voted for Barack Obama
he was the best president ever and you
see this in the film it's actually I
think one of the first films I've seen
where Barack Obama's name and President
Obama has come up but but you see that
in society all the time on this issue
somebody was saying that I've seen get
out four times as the new I would have
voted for Barack
well it cost it it costs two dollars to
make the movie and you've made a
gazillion dollars talk about the the
finding zillion yeah the one the one
gazillion because I think that's amazing
and now it's in the running the word is
it can be nominated for a Best Picture
talk about how much it cost you to make
and what what you end up making so we so
the movie cost 4.5 million I think it's
a it's made 253 worldwide that's amazing
which is which is amazing and I think
it's part of it is because people see it
in multiple times but for me as a
filmmaker I can't think about budget I
just it's nothing's gonna stop me as
president mama seen introduced you know
III like to think he has you like it I
think I think he would like it no I
would have voted for me a third term as
well there you go I cook you would have
one too something tells me he's seen it
I you know yeah I think so I think he's
him you know he's a nerd but he said
thank you congratulations boy I'm hoping
we're all hoping Oscar all for you
seriously thank you